Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Au printemps dernier, je reçois un mail
de collègues de l’Atelier paysan
m’informant que l’ENIB, l’École
Nationale d’Ingénieurs de Brest,
sollicitait l’Atelier paysan
pour une conférence TEDx.
Je suis membre de l’Atelier Paysan,
je suis sociétaire,
et je suis également diplômé
de cette école d’ingénieurs -
j’ai été diplômé en 2005 -
et donc je me suis dit :
« Voilà enfin venu le moment de retourner
auprès de mon ancienne école
pour partager mon parcours,
mon expérience,
et puis -
ce que j’étais devenu
et ce qu’on pouvait devenir. »
Donc voilà.
Je vais vous expliquer comment on peut,
avec un diplôme d’ingénieur,
devenir paysan producteur
de plantes médicinales.
Et je vais également vous
parler de l’Atelier paysan,
coopérative dont je suis sociétaire,
qui développe les pratiques
d’autoconstruction
en agriculture paysanne.
En 2005, quand je suis diplômé de
l’École Nationale d’Ingénieurs de Brest,
ainsi que ma compagne,
on a très envie de voyager.
Mais on décide tout de même
de travailler, de faire un peu d’argent,
de valoriser notre diplôme.
Donc, je travaille
quelques années pour Renault
dans la mise au point de systèmes
de clim automatique et de chauffage.
C'est une expérience intéressante.
J’en ai retiré plein de choses.
J’ai vu aussi l’énorme dépense
d’énergie, au sens premier,
et d’énergie grise aussi,
pour mettre au point des choses
qui ne m’apparaissaient pas
forcément utiles à l’époque.
On s’y tient ; une fois qu’on a mis un peu
d’argent de côté, on part en voyage.
On va jusqu’en Inde par la route :
Turquie, Iran, Pakistan, Inde, bus, train.
On finit au Népal dans un petit village.
Pour l'atteindre, il fallait des heures
de bus sur des pistes chaotiques.
Au bout de la piste,
il fallait encore marcher plusieurs
heures pour atteindre le village.
On y reste un mois, on enseigne l’anglais
dans la petite école du village
et on découvre des gens
qui vivent en autonomie complète,
qui mangent ce qu’ils cultivent, qui
fabriquent les outils qu’ils utilisent.
C’est une expérience
qui nous a beaucoup marqués.
Ensuite, on rentre en France.
Un vol Katmandou-Roissy, ça fait un peu
un choc après un an de voyage,
mais on est revenu les valises pleines,
les valises pleines de confiance,
de confiance en nous,
en nos capacités à faire ce qu’on voulait.
On a découvert plein de façons de vivre
pendant cette année de voyage.
Et donc on ne retourne pas
travailler dans l’industrie.
Pendant une année,
on raconte notre voyage :
expo photos, des choses comme ça.
On commence du bénévolat dans des fermes
car on commençait à s’intéresser
à la question alimentaire, agricole.
Ça nous taraudait.
On est dans une phase où on est ouvert
à tout ce qui pourrait se présenter.
Et là, ça arrive.
Alors que je suis au fin fond
du Finistère, pas loin d’Huelgoat,
en train de faire du woofing -
du bénévolat dans une ferme -
chez quelqu’un qui vivait en yourte,
qui n’avait pas l’électricité, qui était
quasiment autonome en alimentation.
Il avait « L’âge de faire », un journal
mensuel alternatif que je vous conseille.
Je regardais les petites annonces
pour trouver un nouveau lieu
où faire du bénévolat.
Et là pour une fois,
il y avait une offre d’emploi.
Je lis l’offre d’emploi :
« Maraîchage biologique,
autoconstruction, CAO » -
conception assistée par ordinateur
que j’avais apprise pendant ma formation.
Là, je me dis : « C’est pour moi. »
Donc je retourne au café Internet
du coin mettre à jour mon CV.
Et je suis recruté.
C’était à Grenoble,
donc déménagement à Grenoble.
Et c’est parti pour sept années
de salariat à l’Atelier paysan
en tant qu’ingénieur-formateur.
Je vais finir mon parcours de vie
et je reviendrai
sur l’Atelier paysan après.
Pendant ce temps-là, Marie continue
à faire des stages, du bénévolat.
Elle fait également
une année de formation,
un diplôme agricole dans la Drôme à Nyons,
spécialisé dans les plantes médicinales -
c’est un peu la région là-bas -
et se pose la question -
on cherche une ferme pour s’installer -
est-ce qu’on s’installe
en Rhône-Alpes ou en Bretagne ?
On décide de se rapprocher
de la famille en Bretagne.
Et donc on déménage en Bretagne.
On a trouvé une ferme.
Et aujourd’hui donc, notre projet,
après cinq, six ans, on cultive
une trentaine de variétés de plantes,
une dizaine en cueillette sauvage.
Notre ferme fait une dizaine d'hectares.
En culture, on a qu’un demi-hectare.
On transforme ces plantes
en macérats huileux,
puis en baumes avec la cire, on fait
des sirops et on a deux alambics.
On distille les plantes,
donc on fait des hydrolats,
des huiles essentielles qui vont être
utilisées dans nos autres préparations.
On vit sur une ferme autonome en énergie.
Elle était comme ça,
ça nous plaisait bien.
On a une éolienne Piggott,
c’est une éolienne auto-construite,
des panneaux solaires et un groupe
électrogène au cas où quand même.
Et à ce titre, notre mode de vie actuel -
On est bien content d’avoir fait
une formation scientifique
parce que, pour entretenir
une ferme telle que la nôtre,
on a besoin de compétences
dans plein de domaines.
Pour en revenir à l’Atelier paysan...
L’Atelier paysan, son projet,
c’est de développer
l’autonomie des agriculteurs
sur la question de l’outillage,
que ce soit d’outil attelé au tracteur,
de l’outil à main
ou du bâti qui fait partie
de l’outil des fermes.
L’idée, c’est de favoriser
les installations agricoles
et de les sécuriser.
C’est de se dire que pour qu’une
ferme dure, plus elle sera autonome,
plus elle va être résiliente
et résister aux aléas.
Donc l’autonomie en termes d’outillage
est une forme d’autonomie très importante.
Qu’est-ce qu’on fait pour ça ?
Une première chose qu’on fait,
c’est du recensement diffusion.
C’est-à-dire qu’on va dans les fermes,
on regarde ce qu’ont déjà
mis au point des agriculteurs,
on les met en plans et on les diffuse.
C’est un premier moyen.
À l’Atelier paysan,
on est très attaché à la licence libre,
l’open source autrement appelé,
c’est-à-dire que ces plans
sont diffusés sous licence libre,
ils peuvent être reproduits,
utilisés autant que possible.
Pour nous, c’est vraiment important,
la licence libre, c’est ce qui favorise
l’innovation en quelque sorte.
Il n’y a pas de raison que quelqu’un
qui tout à coup conçoit quelque chose -
il ne l’a jamais inventé tout seul.
Il s’est de toute façon inspiré de tout
ce qu’ont fait ses prédécesseurs.
Il a rajouté une petite goutte,
il a assemblé et il a sorti
quelque chose d’utile.
Il n'y a pas de raison qu'il en tire
une rente pendant des années.
Et surtout le fait que ce soit verrouillé,
ça empêche la poursuite de l’innovation.
Nous, les premiers plans qu’on a publiés -
c’était il y a plus de dix ans -
ils ont été modifiés des dizaines de fois
parce que des utilisateurs
se les ont appropriés,
ont refabriqué les outils,
ont apporté des améliorations
et nous les ont reportés.
Comme ça, très rapidement,
les outils évoluent,
s’adaptent à chacun, se partagent,
et ça fait une émulation
très propice à l’innovation.
Une autre partie de mon métier, c’était
de former les paysans à la soudure.
On faisait des formations de cinq jours.
Une dizaine de stagiaires
arrivaient le lundi,
sans forcément savoir souder,
percer, découper.
J’avais organisé toute la logistique
d’approvisionnement en métal,
matériel agricole, vis.
Et à la fin de la semaine, les stagiaires
repartaient avec leur outil découpé,
percé, soudé.
C’est cette idée
qu’on se forme en faisant.
Dans le monde agricole,
on n’aime pas perdre du temps.
Si on est une semaine là à faire de la
soudure, on ne va pas souder des chutes,
on va faire des choses
qui vont servir dans le champ après.
En fait, c’est très formateur de devoir
faire des choses qui vont être utilisées.
L’autre aspect important
de l’Atelier paysan,
une autre facette de mon activité,
c’était d’accompagner des groupes
de paysans à la conception d’outils.
Il y avait un besoin qui se faisait
ressentir par les usagers,
un outil qui n’était pas proposé
par les agro-équipementiers,
ou qui était trop cher,
quelque chose qui ne se faisait plus.
Là, j’accompagnais un groupe
pour élaborer un cahier des charges,
faire des plans,
fabriquer un prototype,
le tester, le modifier, etc.
Là, on est vraiment dans cette logique
de réappropriation de son outil
et de ses capacités à concevoir.
Ça me tient à cœur à l’Atelier paysan
d’inverser cette logique de conception.
C’est-à-dire qu’on n’a plus
un bureau d’études,
un industriel qui conçoit un outil
hors sol en quelque sorte,
et qui ensuite arrive vers des usagers -
là, c’est un exemple agricole, mais
ça peut s’appliquer à d’autres usages -
et qui vient expliquer à l’utilisateur :
« L’outil est comme ça, tu dois l’utiliser
comme ça, tu dois travailler comme ça »,
et tous les travers que ça implique.
On inverse cette tendance et c’est
l’usager qui définit son besoin,
qui définit comment il veut travailler,
ce dont il a besoin
et qui s’intéresse à la manière
de fabriquer son outil.
Il ne fait pas tout lui-même,
il fait faire,
mais au moins il est à l’initiative
de la création de l’outil.
Et ça, ça change beaucoup de choses.
Venons-en à la low tech,
à la question de l’autonomie.
Low tech, donc c’est utile, reproductible,
durable, accessible.
On visualise tous un peu
ce que ça peut être,
mais sur la question de l’utile,
c’est un peu propre à chacun.
Qu’est-ce qui est utile pour moi
ou pour quelqu’un d’autre ?
Et comment on commence ?
On se met d'accord en fait
sur ce qui est utile.
Et là intervient pour moi, ce qui serait
très important, c'est cette démocratie,
ce débat démocratique,
pour choisir au sein d’une société
au sein déjà de l’Atelier paysan,
au sein d’un club low tech,
mais finalement plus largement
au sein de notre société,
ce qui est vraiment utile et
de quoi on a besoin comme outils.
Pour moi, c’est quelque chose
d’assez fondamental
de remettre du débat démocratique
dans ses choix technologiques.
Car on se rend bien compte que les choix
technologiques sont des choix de société
et ont un impact conséquent sur
notre société, sur nos modes de vie.
J’aime bien dire sur l’autonomie que
c’est un choix d’interdépendance
parce qu’on n’est jamais autonome à 100%.
On choisit en fait
de quoi on est dépendant.
Et ça, ce sont des choix qui doivent
être faits collectivement.
À l’Atelier paysan, récemment,
après des années de réflexion
sur toutes ces questions,
on a fait un constat un peu un peu triste,
mais qui nous a paru important.
On s’est rendu compte du côté inoffensif
de nos actions, de nos alternatives.
On avait beau proposer plein
de choses super intéressantes,
des outils, des techniques,
on sentait bien qu’on devenait un peu
sur une étagère à côté d’autres outils.
On ne changeait pas le monde
en quelque sorte.
Et on a voulu faire -
On a fait ce constat
qu’on était inoffensif
et je pense qu’il est
important de le faire.
On est dans un monde libéral, capitaliste.
La main magique du marché ne va pas
tout d’un coup s’emparer de la low tech
et dire : « C’est ça qu’il faut faire. »
Parce que la low tech, elle ne rapporte
rien, elle fait faire des économies.
Ça ne va pas se faire tout seul.
Je voulais en revenir à cette nécessité
de débat démocratique sur ces questions.
Alors comment on fait ? Qu’est-ce
qu’on fait ? Comment on avance ?
Déjà, en en parlant.
Une des pistes soutenues
par l’Atelier paysan -
ce n’est pas nous qui portons tout ça -
c’est par exemple
la sécurité sociale de l’alimentation.
L’alimentation est quand même
un besoin fondamental.
Comment on se réapproprie
cette question-là ?
Et comment on décide
ce qu’on veut dans nos assiettes,
ce qu’on veut que tout le monde
puisse avoir dans son assiette.
À partir de ce moment-là, les outils -
Le débat sur les outils va venir après.
Parce que forcément, en fonction
de ce qu’on veut dans nos assiettes,
on va avoir besoin d’outils
pour répondre à ces besoins.
Et c’est en se réappropriant -
Le projet, c’est la sécurité
sociale de l’alimentation.
Donc on veut socialiser cette question-là,
se réapproprier notre alimentation
et définir les outils qui vont avec.
Mais je pense que
sur de nombreuses questions,
on pourrait fonctionner
de la même manière.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)